it is great to be joined today by will
Sommer who's a tech reporter for The
Daily Beast also author of the right
Richter newsletter on conservative media
well it's great to talk to you I want to
start breaking down this totally failed
farcical attempt to get women to falsely
sexually accuse Robert Muller of sexual
assault there's a bunch of different
moving parts and sort of people involved
how would you if someone knows nothing
about what happened how do you sort of
give them the basic outline of the story
here
sure absolutely so basically Jack
Burkman is kind of notorious within
Washington lobbyists he's sort of known
for being willing to do anything to get
himself in front of a camera he teamed
up with Jacob wool a sort of an equally
notorious young man on Twitter a big
Trump supporter and so they allegedly
were offering women money to accuse
Robert Muller of sexual harassment but
it quickly fell apart in kind of
spectacular fashion and Jacob was
revealed to be running this kind of fake
intelligence firm and it so it really
went south for them what was the first
signal that we heard about that this may
because there were some teases that
something big was coming and Jacob Walt
he's that I think the gateway pundit did
the same when did we sort of realize
that the teasing of the story and the
sort of way it was concocted was really
the story rather than these potential
accusers absolutely so this is a really
complicated story basically a couple
weeks before this all fell apart last
week a lot of reporters got an email
from a person who may or may not exist
it was this woman claiming that Jacob
wool and Jack Burkman were offering her
money no one's actually managed to talk
to that person but this kind of got a
lot of gears turning and so then someone
another woman has come out on the record
and said she was also offered money so
this whole thing is it it was a real
debacle for both Jack Burkman and Jacob
wool they were being very cagey about it
Jacob wool was saying he wasn't involved
in you know finding these supposed to
accusers and he was saying he was you
know he his intelligence firm had they
listed all these employees but they were
just employees of people
actors and models and so I mean that was
really I think the sign where that that
something was really up here and this
wasn't just another sort of a me-too
case I was on the the Moller she wrote
podcast yesterday and we were sort of
talking about okay there should be
significant reputational damage to Jacob
wall and Jack Burkman but what about the
possibility here of criminal charges in
an investigation because there are
potentially a bunch of different crimes
that were committed here yeah really
what took this out of the realm of sort
of weird anonymous email sent to
reporters and into the realm of news is
the fact that the Moller special
counsels team has been tipped off to
this because reporters came to them and
said you know what do you think of these
allegations about Muller and they said
well we referred this the idea that
people are being paid to accuse Muller
we've referred this to the FBI so you
know I think potentially Jacob and Jack
have opened themselves up to some legal
liability I mean if they really were
offering people money I think you're
looking at potentially wire fraud
charges
you know additionally for Jacob you know
just just on a much more basic level he
really appears to have been practicing P
I work without a private investigators
license we talked to a woman who said
she had hired him and he sort of made
off with 1,200 dollars of hers in an
unrelated case and it seems like that
work definitely would have required a
private investigator license so you you
know it seems as though they're kind of
like their hijinks may have some serious
consequences for them and there are
people in my audience obviously who have
no idea who Jacob Wall is and have never
heard of this name before but he is
actually a sort of notorious Trump
supporter on Twitter someone who's been
retweeted by the president I don't know
offhand if he personally knows Donald
Trump but this is not some random person
this is somebody who's been pretty
front-and-center as one of the big
supporters of this administration that
at least on online seems to have been
signal boosted by Trump himself
absolutely I mean I think part of the
reason this case got so much attention
is I think there's a lot of people on
Twitter who were really waiting for
Jacob Wall to to get his comeuppance
this is a guy who's it seems to have
been introduced to Republican politics
by his father who's a regular Fox News
guest Jacob has kind of had a storied
he's
only 20 but he's already had kind of a
very patchy career when he was 17 he had
a claim to have a hedge fund
apparently that went south and he was
banned from trading futures forever for
his whole life and so this you know it's
he's a colorful character and he seems
to kind of stepped in it once again here
yeah and I remember seeing this
interview that he did on it was either
Fox News Review er and he was on this
round table and they were debating what
Jacob wall 17 years old thinks about
biotech and I was sort of thinking hey
it's an it illegal to be running a hedge
fund when you're under 18 years old or
and that that question didn't even come
up well as it turns out maybe there's a
good reason you know I think Jacob
offers the cautionary tale for why we
generally don't have 18 year old
seventeen year old hedge fund managers
so here's for me the most interesting
underlying element of this story is what
we've seen is projection from the right
on so many issues for years so but let's
before we get into this story an analogy
that I've mentioned is voter in person
voter fraud for years the right has been
telling us that in-person voter fraud is
a major problem and yet turns out it's
not quite so easy to get away with and
disproportionately getting caught our
right wingers trying to show up and do
voter fraud to show how easy it is and
then they get caught along the same
lines we've been hearing from a section
of the right about how easy it is to
just make any old sexual assault
allegation and you end the alleged
perpetrators career so easily and once
again here we see that it's people on
the right who were trying to concoct
fake sexual assault allegations and it's
not quite so easy is it no I mean I
think that's a great way to put it I
mean we saw with a lot of these people
the Roy Moore accuser as we saw with
Christine Blasi Ford whenever someone
comes out and says they were sexually
assaulted by a prominent Republican
there their careers are instantly sort
of dragged through the mud and their
whole lives are turned over and so the
idea that you know the Republicans will
say well these people are clearly being
offered money to say this of course it's
absurd I mean unless you're talking
about millions of dollars no one would
go through this for just a couple of
tens a you know a couple grand
and then apparently you know allegedly a
Jack Burkman a Jacob well we're up to
the same thing and and I think they saw
even if they weren't offering someone
money I think they saw that it's not so
easy to you know just kind of pull these
allegations out of nowhere I should say
that they claim to have an affidavit
from this woman we know her name and yet
if she has not appeared anywhere they
claimed she was gonna appear then there
was kind of like a lot of shady business
around why she didn't appear and no
reporter has talked to her since then so
it it's a very strange situation it
seems as though this woman is real but
you know her story has been very you
know it has been muddled by by all the
chicane eree Jack Burkman to Jacob all
have been up to what related to sort of
the truth or falsity of allegations i've
been commenting lately that although
there's this understandable natural
instinct from those who care about the
truth as as closely as it can be
ascertained to fact-check
and to get the truth out there when you
have the successful sort of debasement
of whether we should even care about the
facts which i think is what we've seen
with everything from faking you the fake
news meme to so many of the other sort
of tricks and techniques that have been
used by the trump administration and his
followers what i worry about is that
like the truth of a lot of these things
ultimately doesn't matter because
they've decided we're not really going
to worry about fact-checking and truth
and so on and to me that's like the most
dangerous element of stories like this
which has had it succeeded it could have
done serious damage potentially two
molars reputation and and to those who
want to see the investigation completed
the fact that it failed in the way that
it did does not really seem to have any
negative impact on the the movement that
exists around defending Trump in this
way and I don't know what can be done
about that because you do have a side
now who just says facts are this kind of
vague thing and it's all fake news and
bias anyway yeah absolutely you know I
was sort of struck with how quickly this
one collapse I thought that they might
have had more legs in the right-wing
media but really even Gateway pundit
Jacob wools employer they dropped it
pretty quick perhaps
because the FBI was involved so but you
could easily see this if it had been in
the hands of maybe some more some more
professional some less comical operators
you could see this being sort of
injected into into the media especially
in the way that you know so often this
something will come out and then the
media the mainstream media spend so much
time trying to debunk it or something
like that and then it gets fueled like
another like trump claiming for example
the 3 million votes were cast illegally
in 2016 or something like that but this
one really you know it was done pretty
much as soon as it started is there any
lasting impact that you can identify - I
mean now we've seen so Pizza Gate for a
while was being repeated in a bunch of
different places there were of Alex
Jones before he was kicked off of all
sorts of platforms at one point read
some kind of clearly crafted by lawyers
statement about if something related to
Chobani yogurt I think I don't even
remember at this point which conspiracy
theory it was but does it have any
lasting impact on the those who
perpetuate these conspiracies and false
stories even when they've been debunked
or does it just sort of go away you know
it it kind of depends I mean certainly
in the case of when legal action is
taken I think that that's kind of when
people start to pay attention and when
someone like Alex Jones I think has
become much more gun-shy after and after
Pizza Gate and after being sued by a
variety of people so you know that's on
the other hand you know it remains to be
seen what's gonna happen here to Jack
Burkman and Jacob well I mean certainly
in terms of their their prominence I
mean they're not at the level of an Alex
Jones but but nevertheless I mean this
is within DC specifically I mean Jack
Burkman has done this going back for
years these kind of these hoaxes press
conferences and so you know he seems to
show no signs of stopping when it comes
to the bigger picture strategies that
the left can maybe put in place not just
to fight the misinformation because like
I said I feel like when you start doing
point counterpoint and fact-checking
individual stories you you're often sort
of at a structural disadvantage like
what do you think the left should be
doing in this era that we have over the
last two years of news we don't like his
face
and the media is the enemy of the people
like what strategy do you think left
media should take you know it's really
hard I'm not sure I mean you know the I
think certainly the way this Jacob will
Jack Burkman thing was handled went
pretty well but you know it's if they
were really undone I would say largely
by their own incompetence rather than
anything else yeah I was one one story I
was thinking of was around the entire
immigrant caravan somewhere this meme
started of hey you know what Eric
Trump Don jr. and Ivanka benefited from
birthright citizenship because their mom
wasn't a citizen at the time and I
immediately said this is a really bad
idea
primarily because it's not true but
because the right is extraordinarily
good at discrediting an entire movement
on the basis of one false claim like
Trump's first three kids benefited from
birthright citizenship and then you're
just going to be ignored when you're
actually making good arguments against
using an executive order to change
birthright citizenship or whatever else
you're doing that does not seem to stick
to the right in this way of hey listen
you were wrong on this one thing and we
need to question your credibility in
general so it really pains me sometimes
when I see these memes start to get
oxygen on the left which I know aren't
true
and are just going to do damage I feel
like there's something there that the
left really needs to understand because
it's not that you should be discredited
on everything because listen you you
share this meme about birthright
citizenship for three people that didn't
get it but I feel like the left is not
conscious enough of the fact that the
right is just waiting for them to make
mistakes in that way I think that's a
that's absolutely right yeah I mean the
in sort of the way that like one person
on the Left will say something that it's
you know offensive or disagreeable and
then that is then picked as like the
that I like the face of the Democratic
Party I think that's a very very good
insight before we go we'll the right
Rick their newsletter tell us about what
that is because I find it super
interesting yeah thank you it's a weekly
newsletter covering sort of the goings
on in the right-wing media and you know
conservative internet conspiracy
theories all that kind of good stuff and
you know I try to you know keep it you
know
Fonda as fun as these things can be
while also you know I think for a lot of
people understandably you know you don't
necessarily want to go tromping through
4chan or listening to Rush Limbaugh's
radio show or something and yet I think
there these things are having a really
an increasing effect on our on our
country and so you know I try to keep
people in the loop on all that stuff so
right Richter calm and that'll take you
to the Daily Beast's newsletter page
we've been speaking to will summaries a
tech reporter for The Daily Beast also
author as I mentioned of the right
Richter newsletter on conservative media
will thanks so much for taking time to
talk to me today hey thanks for having
me